ich denke frauen sind nicht grausam im
der meydan proteste und der krim
frauen hat putin wohl nicht gerechnet
rette sich wer kann es herrscht krieg
film gemacht mascha kondakowa geboren
männern wirken diese soldatinnen selbst
ist nicht einfach wenn man eine
besetzung hatten sich schon viele frauen
brutalen kampf haben aber dafür
wofür kämpfen sie die ukrainischen
kalaschnikow vor sich hat und nicht weiß
in extremsituationen ziemlich nerven
herzzerreißende szene abschied von
1989 in kiel wir treffen sie in paris
freiwillig gemeldet das dokumentiert der
wie sie funktioniert man muss wissen wie
vielleicht mehr psychische stärken
soldatinnen für ihre familie ihre stadt
stark
ehemännern vätern frauen und kinder
wissen wie man sachen anders dirigiert
man sie benutzt wenn man sich
film award
hier lebt sie seit acht jahren die
entschieden hat die waffe in die hand zu
irland
er begleitet von 2014 bis 2016
und organisiert ich habe gesehen wie
verlassen die ukraine männer im alter
nehmen
frauen im krieg ich war total schockiert
ich kämpfe an der frontlinie verkehr wo
aktuelle solidarität auf der place de la
und wie ergeht es den drei frauen aus
lehrer sich verhält wie sie sich verhält
von 18 bis 60 müssen bleiben und ihr
soldatinnen im donbass die an der
république feiert auch die kämpfende
von den fragen der journalisten
die russischen panzer versuchen unsere
wirklich sie beeinflussen alles und
massas film heute sie hält kontakt die
land verteidigen das sind die einen
vordersten front kämpfen sie hat den
nichts für ungut aber es ist lächerlich
verteidigung zu durchbrechen ich bin
frau
organisieren sich die dinge um sie herum
so wie sie haben gemachten egl aber sie
eine kämpft immer noch in der nähe des
eine von denen die verhindern dass sie
bilder aber und das wird selten gezeigt
wie es ihnen passt und die männer folgen
für mich ist es wichtig zu sehen dass
das tue ich aber ich will euch eins
donners schwere tage stehen ihre vor
sind da um krieg ja ich achte darauf
marian ein ukrainisches gewand trägt
ihnen weil es so gut klappt mit diesen
sagen ich verteidige nicht nur kiew oder
es gibt nicht nur die die fliehen auch
ihrer ist bei ihren eltern in der west
eine ukrainische flagge denn die ukraine
intelligente leute wissen dass man in
die ukraine nicht mal nur euro
viele soldatinnen verteidigen die
ukraine
jedem job einen tag hat um seine sachen
kämpfen für ihre freiheit für die
und
wir verteidigen die ganze welt
ukraine gegen russland vor einem jahr
zu reinigen sich selbst zu waschen
liberté und diese solidarität gibt mir
lehrer ist nicht in der ukraine zur zeit
waren es 31.000 heute sind es
weiß ich noch hinzufügen würde zu dem
sondern in deutschland fährt ein kind
die hoffnung dass wir gemeinsam eine
das ist normal das sind die vorschriften
wahrscheinlich sehr viel mehr im zuge
zukunft in frieden errichten können ich
einen dreijährigen jungen und
was sie sagt in der demokratischen welt
in der armee aber warum stellen wir
nicht in der ganzen welt aber in der
bin äußerst berührt und beeindruckt von
demokratischen kämpfen wir für die
nicht die gleichen fragen auch einem
dieser geste
mann
demokratie für die freiheit
über 2000 kilometer entfernt steht in
in der ukraine liegt der frauenanteil in
kiew eine andere kriegerin die mutter
als die invasion begonnen hat hat sie
der armee offiziell bei 15 prozent in
heimat statue der film aber zeigt drei
ihre mutter angerufen und gesagt mama
manchen ländern ist er zwar höher aber
kümmert sich um den jungen ich breche
echte front kämpferinnen lehrer die
wohl nie gingen so viele frauen an die
auf und ihre mutter hat natürlich nein
ehemalige journalistin
front macht das den krieg weniger brutal
nein gesagt aber sie hörte nicht auf
eine mine richte sanitäterin beide beine
ihre mutter der junge sagte ich gebe all
es steht alles auf dem spiel da kann man
ab
meine spielsachen weg lasst uns
und da ist alena alle front norwich
sich nur verteidigen und es müssen auch
flüchtlinge hier in unsere wohnung
kommen ich gebe alles aber gehen nur
die kämpfen die gar nicht wollen und
genannt
nicht
überhaupt nicht dazu ausgebildet sind es
ich war im krieg und vorher war ich
da ist seine mutter geblieben nicht
total unpolitisch und das einzige was
zurück an die front gegangen
ich mit meinem film ausdrücken wollte
ist was passiert im inneren in der seele
trotzdem bleibt sie eine kämpferin
im geist wenn der tod einen täglich
umgeht und wie überwinde um diese frauen
in unserer wahrnehmung muss eine
ihre ängste ihre müdigkeit um
weibliche kriegerin eine amazone sein
weiterzumachen
wie ein weiblicher rande nein das ist
und da habe ich gesehen dass es keine
philosophie mehr gibt
eine ganz kleine person die einen helden
denn jedes mal wer geht man nur so und
wird und darum geht's
das habe ich gefilmt und neben manchen
[Musik]